i had a circle jerk session with my  friends but then we didn't want to jack  off seeing each other we played the porn  we'll be sitting at the edge of the  couch like this on the other side so you  see like [ __ ] heads like that  and then just [ __ ] bump in like this  would you be down to do that now i don't  know man  i don't know man why would i  what does it do for me three couches  just like this put it right there right  we hire two strippers they start making  out we start jerking and then we just  jerk off to each other and we just check  in to make sure we all feel good check  in all right who's going to start with  me  my hands are officially in my pants  right now no they're not a liar so happy  hour  dude anthony is i think he's a wild dude